supongamos que tenemos una función f x
igual a x al cuadrado más x menos 6 todo
esto sobre x2 entonces tenemos
curiosidad vemos esta función y queremos
saber cuál es el límite de fx mientras
se extiende a 2 entonces lo primero que
hace es lo que quieres intentar hacer es
ver qué sucede cuando evaluarse en dos
que es f evaluada en 2 ahora bien esto
no siempre será el límite aún si está
definido pero es una muy buena manera de
iniciar para ver si algo razonable sale
de aquí si evaluamos efe en dos en
nuestro numerador obtendremos 2 al
cuadrado más 2 menos 6 entonces 42 menos
6 eso es 0 en el numerador es cero y 0
en el denominador cierto y qué nos dice
eso eso nos dice que la función no está
definida entonces lo voy a escribir aquí
por lo tanto efe no está definida si
fuera una función continua otro gallo
cantará entonces en ese caso si sería el
límite si se podría evaluar vaya pero
bueno aquí aquí no
aquí vemos una función una función que
no está definida entonces vemos si
podemos simplificarlo esto es bueno
claro
vamos a intentar también graficar lo de
alguna manera primero vamos a factorizar
esto en el numerador a esta expresión la
podemos reescribir de la siguiente
manera recordando el curso de álgebra 12
números cuyo producto sea menos 6 y suma
sea 1 esto podría ser 3 y menos 2 cierto
entonces tenemos x + 3 por x 2 todo esto
sobre x menos 2 y siempre y cuando x no
sea 2 estas dos cosas se pueden cancelar
ajá pero entonces podríamos decir que
esto es igual a x + 3 x 3 para todas x
excepto x igual a 2 entonces x distinta
de 2 y otra manera de ver esto de
reescribir a nuestra f x lo voy a hacer
en color azul es la misma función
podemos reescribir a fx decir que esto
es igual
x 3 cuando x es distinta de 2 o decir
que está indefinida cuando x es igual a
2 así que dada esta definición queda aún
más claro cómo podemos graficar efe x
cierto
así que intentemos hacerlo aquí voy a
esto esto no es una línea recta
esto es una línea recta o que esto está
mucho mejor esto es mi eje igual a fx y
acá tenemos nuestro eje de las equis
saja y bueno está definido de esta
manera fx es igual a x + 3 si estoy aquí
es aquí tenemos 1 1 2 3 y aquí se
intersecta y la pendiente es de 1
entonces está definido para todo x
excepto cuando x es igual a 2 entonces
aquí tenemos x igual a 1 x igualados por
lo tanto cuando x es igual a 2 más o
menos por aquí justo aquí está
indefinido y por lo tanto
así se mira la función f x nuestra
función f x se ve así ahora bien dado
esto vamos a intentar responder a
nuestra pregunta cuál es el límite de fx
mientras x tiende a 2 entonces bueno
podríamos ver esto gráficamente mientras
se aproxima a 2 desde valores menores
aquí tenemos x igual a 2 supongamos que
llegamos al 1.7 entonces vemos que
nuestra efe x estará más o menos por
aquí si llegamos al 1.9 nuestra efe de x
estará más o menos por acá entonces
parece ser que si se aproxima a este
valor de aquí similarmente si nos
aproximamos a 2 desde valores mayores
que 2 si estamos supongamos que no sé de
2.5 en 2.5 en nuestra fx está por acá
entonces vemos que poco a poco estamos
más cerca de 200 otra manera de pensar
en ello si camináramos por esta línea
vamos por aquí y vamos caminando por esa
línea entonces vemos que en esta
dirección positiva parece ser que
aproximamos a este valor y si caminamos
por esta dirección la de valores menores
que 2 vemos que también nos estamos
aproximando a este valor y ese es el
valor de x 3 y decimos que x es igual a
2 entonces este valor es igual a 5 si
simplemente lo visualizamos esto es 5
significamos una línea con pendiente 1 y
la intersección es en x igual a 3
este valor será 5 ahora podríamos hacer
esto numéricamente así que vamos a hacer
esto numéricamente ok lo intentamos aquí
están aquí está esto lo borro y lo nuevo
que está es nuestra función original así
está definida así que intentamos meter
valores cada vez más cercanos a 2 por
ejemplo primero para poner el primer
ejemplo 1.999 ahí está esto nos va a
acercar bastante al sumarle 3 nos acerca
bastante a 5 como puedes ver si yo meto
aquí más 9 es más cercanos estaremos a 5
ahora
intentamos valores mayores que 22.000
también nos acerca bastante a 5 nos
estamos acercando a 5 desde el lado
positivo y ya sea que lo vemos
numéricamente o gráficamente parece
bastante claro que el límite en esta
función el límite de esto será 5 y bueno
nos vemos